Jordan came to play with a lot to say
tick-tock let's make a rock Colton was
in tears over his virginity and Jason
won the day this was the bachelorettes
men tell all
and it's time for roses and rose hey we
are here recapping becca kufran season
of The Bachelorette this was an N tell
all episode so I got a big ol glass of
wine for these guys okay it was petty it
was dramatic you act like it was
emotional it's heart-wrenching let's
dive right in
first of all as always I want to know
what did you think of the men tell all
were you disappointed did you get all
the answers you wanted to get or did you
love it so much
tell me so with every men tell all Chris
introduces the guys and we start with
Jake who who who are these people I
don't know I don't know who they are
then luckily he moves into some names
that I do know and then we end with
wills and Colton and Jason and those
three the end that really felt like the
little bachelor possible section right
after watching men tell all
who do you want for the bachelor tell me
wills Colton Jason someone else
I interviewed Chris Harrison very
recently and got his thoughts on a
possible rogue a candidate I'm gonna put
that interview up for you guys
[Music]
here take em we love a surprise don't we
so someone who's not there is Lincoln
and I know why because the man who was
convicted of a crime was not invited I
talked to Chris Harrison about this and
he had a lot of adamant things to say
which I really admired he always gives
his opinion doesn't he and that
interview is up a TT online doctor
I'm drinking because it's a shameless
plug even though I'm not saying
shameless plug but you guys know the
deal anyway I want to do something you
guys that we yep Hawaiians already
affected me everybody I want to do
something that we have never done before
for the men tell all which is a foolish
fashion breakdown what were these guys
wearing I mean what a lineup grocery
store Joe is the one and they're usually
always is one who went way too casual I
like your shirt Joe but where's your
jacket it was nice to see him again I
interviewed I mean he drank it already
Atlantic but too casual I think then we
have the blonde guy who I believe his
name is Nick and his deep V is too deep
a toe then the V gets deeper over with
Connor and what is that jacket that's a
bold print and what are those glasses I
never saw those on the show I'm not sure
that those are prescription Jordon
shockingly the fashion model maven man
looked the most normal his hair is so
flat and smooth I don't even know how to
describe it it looked different but in a
way that I didn't fully understand and
then Chris I would call a bit of a scary
magician leo is the year 1974 wills in a
full plaid suit top to bottom with some
red shoes well that's just wills isn't
it wills you accept these red rose shoes
Colton is all black everything with a
subtle Paisley and a little pink pocket
square and I didn't hate that look but
I'll be honest I didn't love it Jason
looks the best of all and thank God you
guys he got a haircut I'm joking
Chris what happened the wheels fell off
Chris if you remember Chris he really
lost it and he admitted the wheels fell
off and that is great I want to drink
every time somebody owned it tonight
because if there is one rule to being a
reality star and being successful its
owning it you can mess up you can but
you got to own it and Chris owned it so
cheers to Chris Paul no matter what you
say right here you played all of us whoa
Colton came to play drink for Colton he
went right for Jon Blunk I don't really
know why because they weren't a thing on
the show but Cole just went in for it he
had a stern look on his face pretty much
all night I feel right now is it's okay
take it back in three seconds burn
Colton but then oh my god Jon Bloch came
back with a disgusting comment do you
act like a god you know I've been saw
know what's good they bleeped it out I
am NOT a fan of what he said you guys I
don't think it's okay to refer to parts
of the female body in a negative way as
if they represent something negative I'm
not a fan of that use your words more
wisely be better nope man I do have to
say though Colton says the word dissing
genuine and you guys it's not a word I
don't know why people say that on this
show so much it's disingenuous not
disingenuous here's my problem is that
love is a very very powerful emotion
okay then we get the adult of the night
Jason Jason comes for Jean Blanc and
says quote and I have no respect for
anybody that abuses that emotion when
they're in need and Jean you were indeed
what a good way of putting this Jason
that Jean Blanc was basically using the
word love seemingly Jason's implying in
an attempt to stay on the show yeah I
think that that's right
and Jason he tells Jon Blunk and more
importantly your own apology to back up
Jason came to play and he is playing
like an adult
Wow did Jason come off well this episode
you guys we're gonna get more into it
you're gonna call me a hypocrite oh yeah
these are its birthday group date things
are over with t I'm really glad we got
that behind us
fast forward you're leaving practically
on TS terms so then Jordan came for
Colton and I got a drink for Jordan
drink for Jordan because he's not wrong
mmm
Jordan calls Colton out for calling him
a fake when he says really Colton was
being a hypocrite
the thing is Jordan might say what he
says I've got billboards up in all their
minds for paving highways but he's often
wrong
he's just extreme and as he says he's
himself on me I'm unapologetically me
I'm always gonna be me think about the
seriousness of the entire thing right
sure David is talking and David I'm
sorry I don't care I don't know anything
about you that's what I wrote down
I felt like Jordan never attacked you
David I felt like David you were kind of
a bully consistently poking at Jordan
yes defending himself Jason then defends
Jordan I love it I loved Jason on this
episode what did you guys think did
Jason's mental all appearance make you
want him for bachelor even if he wanted
somebody else I was really here for
Jason he was the voice of reason and
guys if we're being honest the mental is
a bit of a bachelor audition isn't it I
mean I talked to Chris Harrison about
this backstage and you can check out the
interview of course there's a lot of
time for the bachelors officially chosen
it's the biggest gap of time during the
year between bachelor nation shows and
things could change but men tell all
matters and Jason made it a night one
then we cut back to those guys from the
beginning who we didn't know and one of
them explains quote we are the guys
eliminated night one I wrote down sad
lol sad the yo to explain yourself Chris
Harrison wasn't gonna take the time he
probably don't know their names
Jordan is then gonna give one of the
night one guys some camera time he gets
up and he knows what the students trying
to do interject themselves just to be on
camera and Jordans like take your time
man
get out here Jordan came to play mmm the
best prisoner that was just Jordan
turning to show and saying grocery-store
Joe what's up George oh it's out on my
back it was so brownie and silly and I
loved it
don't drink every time the Jordan says
he's himself myself myself himself
that's a dangerous game you are you
Jordan and we love it am I think my
Rolls Royce not so much just compares
what are these guys driving
remember on Moe and Joe this guy in the
corner is on Moe and Joe I don't know
what that means you guys what it what
was he talking about please let me know
in the comments I literally have no idea
I think this is a reference I wasn't
getting all right saw what Jordan let me
know grocery Joe's time of the mansion
was fleeting grocery store Joe comes to
the hot seat and he is looking good a
lot of these guys had some little
makeover moments Joe's hair got longer
and curlier and he's just letting his
hair do its natural thing often we look
our best in the natural state that we
have been given by nature says the woman
whose hair is fully highlighted hmm
I recently meant went to my more natural
hair part trying that out let me know
what you guys think used to do a deeper
part does it suck tell me anyway I do
see that you are a man of very few words
yeah that's what everyone says I don't
know I mean I talk a lot I just you know
wait I can just say Joe always a man of
very few words guys and he says he makes
the mistake of saying I talk more
usually but we got the cameras around
here here's the thing I know that Joe
was beloved and I love Joe he's very
sweet but the Joe for bachelor thing
it's not gonna work you guys Chris
Harrison flat out told me backstage at
mental that Joe is not the type of guy
for bachelor he doesn't say enough
you've got to be able to articulate your
emotions and speak at length if you're
gonna be the lead you're carrying things
Joe we love you we're excited to watch
you on paradise are you guys
disappointed about the idea of Joe not
being The Bachelor are you still holding
out
No so then wills is in the hot seat and
the all plaid wasn't my favorite wills
look what did you think did you like it
I didn't love it I think he's looked
better I like him in an animal print I
don't have much to say about wills he
was here in studio check out the full
interview on our YouTube channel if you
missed it I asked him a lot of these
questions with the answer tonight and I
thought he had nice answers and I think
wills is nice I don't think wills is
gonna be the bachelor I'm sorry it's
just I'm feeling not after Jason just
killed it during this episode then we've
got Colton and they addressed the Tia
thing and Colton says he wasn't even
think about tea all season you guys we
have so much more from Colton and Tia on
our website I interviewed Colton and I
interviewed Tia on set in Paradise
talked to them both about each other I'm
gonna check it out Oh a lot of tough
conversations you had to have another
one was about your virginity
Colton's oh man the virginity thing came
up of course especially because of Jon
Blanc's disgusting comment I'm not even
gonna call it a joke because it wasn't a
joke it was a disgusting comment go
higher with your comedy Colton talked
about how he had lied about being a
virgin before and he said something that
really helped make me understand cuz I
don't want to shop you guys but I didn't
play sports he said it as an athlete you
know you build this just wall up that
you don't let your opponents you sweat
and you don't you don't let anybody get
to you this made a lot of sense for me
now it was like he talked about kind of
making things up in the locker room and
he said he didn't want people to see him
sweat because you're an athlete you're
like always competing and I understood
Colton better after this one-on-one with
Chris Harrison and Colton was in tears
up there and I don't blame him I do
think people said a lot of crazy stuff
to him on social media and I do think
that there's a double standard with men
and women and the virginity thing being
okay and I think the Colton has a good
heart
so what did you guys think did you like
Colton's conversation did it make you
seem differently at all and did you
think he addressed everything properly
I've more with Colton on the virginity
thing and how he's handled it
including telling people he had
previously lied to about it yes he's had
those conversations that's up a DTR I'm
calm oh okay man I am plying away
[Music]
deserts food then we've got Jason in the
hot seat and Jason did the thing that I
was concerned he didn't do during
Bachelorette you guys he cried he cried
here's the thing at the end of the day
what we are likely looking at is either
Jason for bachelor or one of Becca's top
two guys at Blake and Garrett for
bachelor Blake and Garrett have gotten
very emotional on the show especially
Blake and Jason did not cry when he was
sent home and I think that Jason is
funny and very well-spoken but you've
got to have a lead who's gonna be
emotional he cried at mental all just
nailing this bachelor audition and I
don't mean that in a way like Jason's a
bad guy I think he's great
you really checked all the boxes and he
said without saying to me that he's had
talks to be the bachelor which doesn't
surprise me I mean usually with the top
view guys there's gonna be that
discussion you know I'm saying do you
want Jason to be the bachelor how do you
feel after tonight tell me that take
oprah's line but I say it with all the
passion oh my gosh things with Jason get
even better I forgot he quoted Oprah
Jason referred to Oprah Oprah and you
get a Jason and you'll get a Jason and
you get a Jason do we all want a Jason
do we want Jason for bachelor he
mentioned Oprah
Oh Jason jawed love it so I guess moving
forward what could I do better to kind
of bridge that gap he said that he
wanted more answers from Becca and I
agree but we're not gonna get them guys
Becca is so sweet and so kind that she
doesn't give the strongest of opinions
even a mentor law and even in my
interview with her she still just said
basically with Jason she was just kind
of following her heart didn't give a ton
of specifics on why she sent him home
did that bother you at all did you want
more answers from Becca tell me okay
then
Jason and Becca come face-to-face and
Jason tells him I can't it's like drink
every time Jason gets even better mmm I
was Blake for Bachelor I still like
Blake but I also really like Jason now
I'm feeling torn just like Becca did but
that was between Blake and Garrett and
I'm between Blake and Jason anyway so
Jason just tells Becca that he thinks
she is a wonderful person and that she's
gonna do so much in the world and he
just hopes they can be friends what an
adult thing to say I didn't even know I
could say those things very impressive
then may I come up there yeah yeah Jon
Blunk asks to join Becca up there john
wonkey already wasted so much of our
time and everyone is rolling their eyes
how dare he he is so clueless yet again
and he wants to give her a perfume this
is painful Jason and Colton's faces say
it all no one wants to test your perfume
Jon Blunk go home okay guys so yeah
Becca also didn't really have an answer
on why she sent Joe home I mean don't
drink every time Becca doesn't have a
specific answer that's a lot of
negatives it doesn't make much sense
always great to have an excuse devilís
of rose am i right
anyway I just do want to say sorry from
the bottom my heart for that and with
that being said I brought some people to
go ahead and let everyone know how much
of a jerk I am for that okay then
Chris really brought it home
Harrison Chris our although Chris
Harrison he brings it up that was cute
it drinks to owning it he redeemed
himself tonight and I'm excited to see
Mon Paradise and of course we have to
have as usual on the journey with JC JC
come on in you guys today JC is going to
tell us what he sees in how the men tell
all so JC the C stands for coffee today
that's what your drinking is you're
gonna stay up all night editing this
video and because we love this episode
so much we just want to know you always
had the best most adult like Jason
opinions what did you think of the
Mentos there was a lot of big drink
I thought Jordan was the best Jordan is
a guy who can take a lot of heat from a
lot of people at once and he gets
flustered but he handles himself well
Jordan is a guy also is confident anyone
who can play that that well you get to
set ice it from JC JC who's your pick
for bachelor you know I'm a fan of Jason
now to JCC's Jason cheers to Jason and
JC on the journey okay so you guys that
was men tell all we had some funny
little bloopers moments there great
although I just have to say I was
concerned in the bloopers footage we saw
Becca chasing a peacock I don't know
much about animals but I don't think
you're supposed to chase peacocks I
believe that they're an aggressive bird
let me know in the comments if I'm wrong
but I think I heard that somewhere
Oh Google it later I'm not saying
counter peacocks much bring you know
better safe than sorry
anyway in the promo for the finale
speaking of emotion Garrett cries a lot
and Becca calls herself a monster Becca
is so hard on herself and we also got a
very long trailer for bachelor in
paradise
you guys interviews from bachelor in
paradise set are up at et online calm
right now
check them out including with Chris
Harrison who told me that they filmed so
much paradise more than ever before this
season oh my god
the trailer is so intense we had ended
with I think her name is Chelsea from
our season just get your breath god that
was dark feel for you Chelsea are you
guys excited for paradise let me know
it's going to premiere right after the
Bachelorette finale next week you guys
we were already at the end I adore you
all so much thank you for being here
overall a solid episode of men tell all
from style to sadness to borderline
insanity it was wonderful
and I have loved of course watching the
season with you guys and getting your
comments so please keep them coming and
reach out to me anytime
myyy wow this is good I've said it
before I'll say it again for any newbies
look for a rose a that's borderline
clear hold it up to the Sun and if it
almost looks like water you're gonna
love it and it should be from France my
two very basic tips
[Music]